- [Voiceover] Let's try to show that 0.5
is equal to one half.
We often hear people use
these interchangeably.
They use them back and forth.
Maybe someone would say,
I have a 2.5 pound rat
and then someone would say back to them,
wow, a two and a half
pound rat, that's enormous.
If we get past thinking about
how enormous that rat is,
what we can notice is they first said 2.5
and then they changed
it to two and a half.
They use them interchangeably
because they're equal
and that's fine.
You can use these back and forth
because they are equal to each other.
.5 and one half are equivalent or equal
but let's not just accept
that that's true, let's see,
let's see if we can prove it.
Let's try to show that.
So the first way we can show it
is down here with a number line.
We have a number line
that goes from zero to one
and it's divided into
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10 equal pieces
so that means each of these pieces
is one of the 10 equal
pieces or one tenth.
So looking back at this decimal up here,
this five is in the tenths place
so we can also say 0.5 is five tenths
is another way to read that decimal
or we could say five tenths.
So if this distance here is one tenth,
if we travel another one,
we've gone two of the tenths,
two of the 10 equal spaces.
So to get to five tenths,
we're going to travel
one, two, three, four,
five of the tenths
and right here, we have five tenths.
We could write is as a fraction
or we could write is as a decimal.
So we found five tenths
on this number line
but let's see if that really
is the same as one half.
This distance here from zero to one,
if we were to block that off,
going to mark it off,
this point right here
where we said five tenths,
this distance, this whole
distance that we traveled
is this much
and we can see here that this is in fact
half of the distance between zero and one.
This is halfway.
So 0.5 and one half are at the same point
on a number line
so that's one one to
show they're equivalent.
Another way we can show
that five tenths and one half are equal
is with a fraction model.
So here we have a rectangle
and let's try to show one half.
Let's start with one half this time.
So if we split this rectangle in half,
here we're trying to show half.
One out of two equal pieces.
So we'll shade one half,
one of the two pieces.
So this is one half and now,
let's try to show that this
is equal to five tenths.
Remember, this five is in tenths place.
So now, instead of halves,
we're going to divide our
rectangle into tenths,
five tenths,
so let's do that.
Here we go.
So we'll make 10 equal pieces for tenths
and we will shade five of them.
We want to see five of the tenths
so let's do that.
One, two, three,
four and five.
Here, we've shown five tenths
and we can see that it
is equal to one half.
One half and five tenths
cover the same amount
so they are equal.
So we've shown two ways now.
One half and five tenths
were at the same spot
on a number line which means they're equal
and they cover the same amount of area
which is another way
to show they're equal.
So one half is definitely equal
to 0.5 or five tenths.